[Music]
what up guys
welcome back to off the record where we
talk about
whatever we want with two daddies and a
baby
two daddies what were you saying he said
there's a new virus now in
india yeah so there's a new virus in
india hundreds of people got sick and i
think one guy died
is it the samosa virus oh that would be
a good day
that should be like if they have their
own hurricane i know hurricane samosa
hurricane samosa delicious
but um yeah and then they they all got
tested it's not
uh coveted that's [ __ ] it's crazy
dude
do you think this is like mother nature
going like you're overpopulated go to
hell yeah
[ __ ] that's so crazy there's just random
[ __ ] popping up everywhere yeah and they
said there was um
like some theories not for this one but
there might be a lot of [ __ ] that
happened same with global warming
and the uh perma-perma frost
thawing out yeah that like uh germs that
got frozen are being released again
so like old diseases and stuff that
hasn't been around for millions of years
or whatever
that could come back what if we're in
quarantine for like five years
well we all thought it was gonna be
three weeks and this [ __ ] it's the end
of the year
[ __ ] what if there is like what if it
comes to america
dude i think at one point maybe you
should just be like [ __ ] it everyone
just do it on the [ __ ] one
they're like yeah like honestly most of
you guys are gonna die
but it beats staying inside so they're
just like go outside
you know what's crazy is that these
pandemics
in the past they changed like
the whole structure like economic
structure power structure
everything of different societies like
you know um
the the black death the plague yeah it
killed so many people in europe
60 of europeans yeah that that all the
whole
it destroyed like that system of like
all the powerful like warlords or
whatever like because
all the farmers were just like well [ __ ]
i don't have to
like and there's like there weren't
enough farmers and peasants right
so they became more more like
independent and powerful
and then um same with like japan too
they had a smallpox
thing and then after a lot of people
died from the smallpox
it changed like their whole system of
like government and everything like
that's probably what's happening now
there used to be a better so during the
black death
um before that it was like death was
something that you should be like
um was it like it's not fearful but
revered
revere again like um so like the the
angel of death would come and it would
be like a
say a bearded person or a bearded baby
that would like carry you away
and then during the black death that's
where all the depictions became of the
green reaper
so now everyone because of that and then
that's changed now
of how people are so afraid of death
than like associating that
from just like the black death and all
these other plagues that have hit us in
the world
so before that it was like oh you die
you die obviously people
like had like their hopes and dreams of
like religion and stuff being real
uh but also like death wasn't obviously
afraid of death in the afterlife
but the depictions on what comes
right after death and like who takes you
away who carries you all those things it
was it was nice stuff
nicer stuff oh depending on what
religion and like where you grew up
yo that's crazy like all those past
pandemics of people like
40 million people dying or like these
numbers were crazy
what was in the 1920s where it was like
you die within six hours spanish flu
that's insane yeah what do they do with
the bodies they just
make a big pile and burn them well they
let a lot of them were war
uh casual like people during world war
one they were just dying in the trenches
this is when they used to wear those
bird masks oh no no that's
that's the black death the bird mask was
because they had a long beak and they
would put
aromatics so they thought because of
like you would catch it from smelling it
right kind of like
through the air like airborne yeah so
then they thought good smells
uh would uh is if you smell something
good you can't catch it
yeah they're like if it's stinky they're
like stinky stuff is what spread disease
that's what they thought
yeah yeah if you're [ __ ] in their
bathroom in your bedroom
but i think that was um renaissance era
it was the fleas it was the fleas that
that yeah it was it was like dark ages
yeah it was the fleas that came
and bit everybody oh man i wish i lived
during those times
everyone was stinky everyone smelled
like [ __ ] yeah when you go to
whorehouses you go fire you got beers
you gotta put them did you go to the
the horror smell like [ __ ] everyone why
would you want to go to the horror i was
like
they all got syphilis and [ __ ] but
knowing what i know now and going back
in that time
but one out of three meals gave you
diarrhea probably i'll cook my own food
i'll shower so ugly back then yeah but
beauty standards are different like
they're like
guys like me you know that's
oh wait no i don't know if that's true
well i think uh like say like in the
greek or roman uh depictions of like
beauty
they were but they were clean though
yeah so okay then if i had to go back in
time
roman era is cool yeah it'd be either
like roman or greek or who knows though
because they're clean because they
actually have bath houses
or asia bathed every day for hours asia
also had bath houses yeah the medieval
times like
up north those fools were nat like the
europeans
after rome fell and the dark ages
i don't know man they start inventing
perfume just to smell better
they live better too in terms of how
say your body's supposed to like live
and function and like just work
so they're supposed to be breaking up
your sleep schedule into four hour
naps so what they would do is um they
would
all roughly sleep around the same time
take a four-hour nap get up two-hour
walk
and then take another four-hour nap they
just walk straight up for two hours
get the exercises and stuff yeah oh damn
oh it was called um
the second slumber or something like
that right so they slept 12 hours a day
in europe
no they got like two hours of exercise
they'll be 10 in total well they oh you
talking about the romans
it was one of those people oh i'm like
that's a koi because i break up my sleep
schedule like that sometimes i'll get
like
2 am to 6 and then when i get home like
at two pm
two six i'll sleep that's a four hour
nap yeah
i'll be like oh the romans did it i'm
gonna check out like ancient china
when they were bawling oh like when
they're like in the center like a cell
throughout
something or yeah or the three kingdoms
time or no they were warring all the
time so if you could go back to one era
where would you go
i want to be on like an air balloon and
watch like genghis khan's crew but
i don't know if i want to live with them
you know pretty crazy huh
i do want to go back to a clean place
though i like being clean
yeah so i want to go back to a clean
place and i think i need to go back to
a place where people look like me like
asia yeah yeah cause if i don't
i'm like i'm in the middle of like
africa or europe
and they've never seen another asian
they might freak out and think i'm an
alien and kill me
that's true well they've seen they have
they've had passages of like
going through and from because like in
in those societies like
so ancient egypt um if you look at the
history of it from back then
they did have like uh people of all
types right
so there was like um i think was uh
queen nefertiti was like a black woman
they had other kings and fellow that
looked like more just like me or a
little bit darker
so they had it was multicultural but
that makes sense though that's like
middle east north africa
yeah that makes sense right but then if
they see a random like chinky-eyed
person they might go
who the [ __ ] is this one after they've
had trades of like things like coming
too dude because there was the silk
route and [ __ ] or like they made their
way
on land you know the the the huns
they're saying that those guys were um
mongolians
mulan enemy right uh they're the guys
that
gave the romans some [ __ ] they're like
they came all the way up into like
northern europe
but their description of
the the romans descriptions of the huns
they sound asian
oh crazy like mongolian or chinese
always practicing kung fu and [ __ ]
[Laughter]
so you don't know when you would go
because egypt would be dope too
if you're on the good side you're not
the slaves i want to watch
that's true watch the pyramids get built
like how the [ __ ] did they build that
[ __ ] they still don't know right
i mean if aliens didn't do it i would
have been like i knew it [ __ ]
it was just humans and a lot of them
i forgot who said it was like like i
think it was louis soukay who was like
he had this joke where was like
um of course of course not
but so like of course slavery was bad
of course it was the worst thing that
ever happened yeah
but every single human feat in history
has been done by throwing human death
and suffering at things
yeah and that's literally like what it
was like like great wall of china
got a bunch of chinese people in those
walls man
it was generations of people like they
had like it was i think it took
um it took more than three generations
of families to build the great wall
yeah and then if people died it just
pushed them in yeah can you imagine
that kind of like project where you're
like half of your life
you're just watching this project being
built
and you're not even gonna be alive to
enjoy it
who was the guy was it genghis khan that
when he died
uh all the people that attended his
funeral were killed so they wouldn't
give out that secret location
yeah it was one of those guys where it's
like
every time the chief died or whatever
his wives
his servants everybody would die they
would kill them
or bury them alive so they can [ __ ]
go to the afterlife
that [ __ ] is nuts man imagine being
like the homie to that guy you're like i
love being a homie but can i please stay
alive
you know what sucks though is like how
do you know
in the afterlife they're gonna still
work for you they might be
like like this ghost now like i got
different rules [ __ ] i'm a ghost too
like [ __ ] you man you killed me
yeah and then now you're just haunted
for the rest of your ghost life
with all these people that hate you
because like they're like you
you [ __ ] killed me man or like you
know there's it's like supposed to be
karma right so like if you'd lived a
really good
peaceful life you're supposed to get all
kinds of riches or whatever
so it could be you were uh like genghis
khan's like best buddy
but since you were a scholar you didn't
kill people and then when you go
into the afterlife now genghis ha han
khan is in hell and you're like get out
get all these riches so he's servicing
you now
could be whoa trip out that'd be sick
but i'm scared of him
him well i guess you can't die anymore
yeah i mean so then nothing would matter
yeah that's true well i mean if you're
both ghost he could probably still hurt
you do you think
do you think he had insurance on his
horses i think he did
yeah because it's important because you
gotta insure those bad boys
and uh speaking of insurance we're
sponsored by
gabby insurance you know you're probably
overpaying on car
and home insurance sure you'd love to
save money but is spending
hours on your own shopping for a lower
rate
maybe to save a few bucks worth it
probably not but what i did
and i use gabby and gabby does all the
work for you in just a few minutes and
get this
gabby customer safe 961
per year on average it's almost a
thousand dollars guys gabby takes the
pain out of shopping for insurance by
giving you
an apples to apples comparison of your
current coverage
with 40 of the top insurance providers
like progressive
nationwide and travelers and that's
really important because you want to
keep the deductible the same what they
cover is the same and that's what they
do the apples to apples
it's exact same coverage but they give
you different uh prices from different
providers
just link your current insurance account
and in just minutes you'll be able to
see quotes for the exact same coverage
you currently have so i signed up for
this and i just want to give you some
quotes i got because you all know that i
recently got
a new old classic car it was a 1988
toyota land cruiser
i love it and i wanted to ensure it and
so they gave me some quotes from
different carriers and they said safeco
was 89 bucks a month
or 1065 a year progressive was 93 bucks
94 for all state
travelers was 97. nationwide was 120 and
so like compared to the insurance that i
was quoted by my company
i roughly save around 30 bucks ish a
month
comparing to all these guys that's like
300 a month and a year
a year would be like almost 400 yeah
400 bucks so if they're saving about 961
on average for a lot of people it's
pretty up there
uh i was quoted pretty good too so
it's pretty awesome because i think that
you can't really find savings like that
they did for me
you know um they'll let you know so you
can relax
knowing that you have the best rate out
there and they'll never sell your info
so no annoying spam or robo calls i was
pretty glad about that part
because i get a lot of junk mail and i
don't want that stuff from
nobody yeah so if you want to see if
you're overpaying for a car
or home insurance see how much gabby can
save you it's totally free to check and
there's no
obligation which is awesome go to
grabby.com off the record
that's g-a-b-i dot com slash off the
record
gabby.com off to record and see how much
money you can save
thank you very much thank you all those
ancient things though i'd be watching
um a lot of youtubers and they're
producing some
good like history channel things really
yeah it's so fun to watch like i used to
watch uh crash course and all that but
there's
new channels i'm going on to like um
armchair historian uh
extra credit uh these you know
there's just like channels now that are
like getting more into specifics of like
certain wars and whatever and i'm like
man it's it's just
it's so fun it's like non-stop game of
thrones non-stop stories
yeah that's tight and it's animated too
like
yeah they put a lot of like work into it
it's crazy to think so like
we're obviously living through this time
now and we know about specific details
and we have the like articles about
every single day something happening
right
but when you go like hundreds of years
back even like 100 years back
everything is generalized per year like
this event happened this year
this thing happened over like 20 years
and it's like there's no like we don't
get to know
unless we make like shows or have our
fantasy about
every single detail that goes into it
and why those decisions are made
because it's like as a collective that's
what like say like they want to invade
this country but there's probably some
internal beef that
people didn't want to do it like you
know how we have like our communities
fighting each other on
wanting to vote this person and this
person in but we don't get to see that
side of it
yeah you see all the little drop like
you have to imagine what the little
drama is
is people like a thousand years from now
can
just watch what happened
during this year 2020 that is crazy they
can see
like people vlogging about their
experience
they can see like what happened every
minute in different parts of the states
like
or the world that's what blows my mind
is like i think maybe that's what the
egyptians feel to though with their
higher griflix they're like can you
imagine people could just come in these
caves and see what we did because we're
comparing it to like the caveman days
and i don't i know how they're like dude
we're [ __ ] legit man
like look at this [ __ ] your shoulder
you're racing it i know
what's crazy is so if you look at just
the evolution of like
a human yeah so humans have been around
say
from when we evolved from primates about
two million years
that's a shitty time yeah a recognizable
human would be about a million thousand
forty thousand
uh a recognizable human will be uh uh
two hundred thousand years are you
talking about primates no even before
that so people that were like uh walking
on two feet
uh maybe harrier and stuff like that but
say two hundred thousand years ago was
it's not forty thousand i have to double
check the facts everything i've read on
was like
from a long time ago and this is the
evolution because evolution takes long
40 000 years is quick not on ancient
aliens though yeah
so then so then 200 000 years ago if you
saw that you'd be like oh that's a human
right uh 200 000 years ago is when we
developed vocal cords
and speech and started making sounds and
that's what really it started advancing
society yeah
um ancient humans were ugly dude
and then but in terms of from when we
had humans
like actual like able to
communicate with each other um because
we already had tools before that
um from 200 000 years ago we only have
6 000 years of history that we know of
from 200 000 years of what could have
been
yeah that's insane i mean we don't know
any of those
um stories about the monoliths like all
those ancient
stonehenge and [ __ ] yeah like all these
buildings
you know like no one knows or like when
i think it was the mayans or the aztec
or whatever
when the spanish came they're like i
don't know where these came from like it
was already here
so it aliens aliens
so people are saying like they they were
built by a different tribe
like ancient times and then they went
somewhere and then when the new
tribes came in they just occupied it so
that's crazy i know that that's [ __ ]
nuts man i want to know
i really want to know if somehow
humans became technologically advanced
and then like not like today's standards
like with with
electronics but maybe in a different way
like they figured out math and all that
stuff
and then like construction and whatever
to a certain point where they can build
this stuff
and then like a disaster happened or
something happened where they had to
like get away
and restart again because it's very easy
for humans to be cavemen
if we didn't have uh all these things
like
imagine like if pretty much like it got
wiped away
right can we teach the next generation
hell no
like even with the knowledge that we
know like we as in us in the room
we can't teach them engineering or we
none of that we just got to survive
our [ __ ] we're so technologically
advanced that like
let's say they put all all of human
knowledge in this hard drive right
and it's right here and then we have to
reset and i find it i'm like oh all the
knowledge is in here i'm like
oh [ __ ] i need a computer to plug in to
access you know
everything is so technologically
advanced it's so compartmentalized that
you
need like five things to make one thing
work that's just so hard
always like turning to comedy for making
it more relatable
uh to like how crazy it is so joe rogan
said something if you put me
on an island with all the things i
needed to like build an iphone or all
these things
if you come back years later he'll be
still smashing uh
rocks with this fish and like he
wouldn't because he wouldn't know how to
do that he's like you need the smart
people to do that and then
um he was like some other guy was like
imagine
you took me back in time and i had to
prove that i was from the future
um and he was telling people they'd be
like he would be like oh like
in a few years we're gonna be able to
communicate with someone across the
world and they're like oh cool how
and he goes oh i don't know i just use
my phone like oh what's the phone
uh it's like how does that work it goes
to a satellite
what's a satellite and he goes [ __ ] and
then he's like give me something easier
he goes oh so who who's the next
president
[ __ ] it's only like 50 years ago you
know i had wikipedia i could tell you
what the president is yeah
he wouldn't be able to he wouldn't be
able to like just prove that you know
i don't think anyone knows what some
ways were so [ __ ] smart that we're so
dumb now yeah i mean
yeah it's like we could drive a car but
can we build one from scratch
[ __ ] no can eat bread but can we bake it
from scratch
yeah like i don't even know breast milk
it's bread material
i mean vegas comes from safeway yeah and
all right
it's sliced it's already sliced yeah i
wouldn't be able to like tell some of
those from the future we can barely
survive if like there was apocalypse
right now
like grow your own food and like live on
it i think like
we're doing the necessary things that we
can we have guns we can like go off road
we can camp we can like
cook but we do those things for fun but
nobody else does
well i guess yeah if we're comparing us
to city slickers
yeah we have a slight advantage i know
how to rob a walmart and grab canned
food out of it yeah
well i feel like most people would be
like hey that's not nice you know
that's survival baby apocalypse that's
not
nice that's not nice
you